today's video is kindly sponsored by
raid shadow legends
hey 42 here as you've probably noticed
planet earth is home to a startling
array of animals both big and small
lift up a rock climb a tree stick your
head into a lake spelunk your way into a
cave
wherever you look
life teams
but here's a mind-blowing random
interesting fact for you
despite the remarkable abundance of life
all around us
it turns out that an estimated 99.9
percent of all the animal species that
have ever existed on earth
have already gone extinct
just as death is a normal part of life
extinction is a normal part of evolution
the quiet slipping away of species over
time is known as the background
extinction rate
it changes from one epoch to the next
but it's always there no matter how good
conditions are for life
but not all species loss is like the
proverbial tortoise slow and steady
every once in a while the extinction
hair rocks up and starts gunning down
unsuspected species faster than legolas
killing orcs at the battle of helm's d
these so-called mass extinctions have
occurred a total of five times in the
history of our planet
no doubt you've heard of at least one of
them the cretaceous paleogene extinction
event that wiped out the dinosaurs 66
million years ago but whilst that's
undeniably the a-list celebrity amongst
extinction events
it wasn't the deadliest
not by a long shot
that title belongs to a cataclysm so
terrible it came within a whisker of
wiping out complex life on earth
and tight
arena battles dungeon runs and clan boss
fights with an alliance of champions
it's the greatest mobile game of all
time raid shadow legends to jump
straight into the action you can use my
links below to download raid yourself to
your mobile phone or pc so recently i've
been grinding out the pvp arena to try
and help me get better in battles
and there's a reason for that the hydra
the biggest baddest and scariest boss
the newest member of raid's huge boss
roster is an absolute beast it has the
ability to share its pain and push
damage from itself onto your team and
cause your champions to rot from the
inside out there's so much to discover
in raid but personally i really enjoy
the pvp arena it's a great way to put
all of my experience during the raid
campaign to good use against other
players so what's new in raid well ray's
giving away a super limited edition
champion to every player in the game
some of you might already recognize him
it's esports legend and navi superstar
simple between now and january the 28th
2022 simple's limited edition champ is
available for free to both new and old
players in raid all you have to do is
log in for seven days and he's yours
this is the best time to get started in
raid and if you use my link in the
description or scan my qr code you'll
get some free resources and a free
mystery champion straight away to
kickstart your game all this treasure
will be waiting for you here and
remember rewards will only be available
for the next 30 days and only for new
players once you're in you can find me
in game under the name 42 and if you're
fast you can join my clan it's that easy
just click the link in the description
and i'll see you in game
today scientists call this catastrophe
the permian triassic extinction event
but it's also known by another
much more fitting name
the great dying
it was quite simply the biggest natural
disaster in the history of life on earth
the great dying took place approximately
252 million years ago and it was almost
unimaginably deadly when the dinosaurs
game over screen arrived on the surface
of a 10 kilometer wide asteroid that
smashed into the yucatan peninsula with
the force of a hundred billion atomic
bombs 66 million years ago
50 percent of all animal species on
earth at the time were deleted from
existence
now it's hard to imagine something more
destructive than an asteroid strike
but during the great dying a staggering
of all species were eliminated
apocalyptic doesn't even cover it
never before or since has complex life
been so close
to disappearing entirely so here's the
million dollar question
if a giant asteroid smashing into the
planet only killed off half of life on
earth
what the hell happened 252 million years
ago
to do away with almost all of it
the truth is
nobody knows for sure
250 million years ago is a very very
long time and much of the evidence we
would need to reach definitive
conclusions
have long since disappeared
trying to figure out the identity of the
ruthless killer that initiated the great
dying
is basically like investigating the
oldest cold case on earth luckily like
the good intellectual detectives they
are a bunch of scientists have spent the
last few decades doing exactly that
between them they've pieced together a
pretty compelling case for the
prosecution of this most massive of mass
murderers
one that not only explains how complex
life nearly ended during the great dying
but that also has a surprising amount of
relevance today 252 million years later
just before the permian triassic
extinction event kicked off history's
most brutal bout of species-related
spring cleaning
a volcanic eruption took place in what
is today siberia
when you picture an erupting volcano you
probably imagine something along the
lines of mount saint helens in 1980
explosive and destructive but relatively
short-lived
the volcano that erupted just before the
great dying
was a little bit different the eruption
of mount saint helens built up to an
explosive finale over a period of a
couple of months
the eruption events that coincided with
the great dying
lasted for two million years
the siberian volcano is fortunate to
have been caused by a mantle plane
essentially a big blob of unusually hot
magma beneath the earth's crust
about 250 million years ago this
particular mantleplume rose up from the
belly of our planet and spewed forth its
molten in its all over siberia like a
drunk after a vindling
to give you an idea of the kind of scale
we're talking about here the mount saint
helens eruption which was one of the
largest in the entire 20th century
coughed up about 2.8 square kilometers
of material
the volcanic event that took place in
siberia in the lead-up to the great
dying
brought forth four million cubic
kilometers of material from the depths
of the earth
that's enough lava to cover the entire
planet in a layer eight meters deep
to state the bleeding obvious that's a
lot of molten rock these eruptions
represent one of the largest volcanic
events ever to have taken place on earth
but it wasn't the eruption itself that
almost wiped complex life out of
existence
or at least not directly
whilst in theory this super volcano
produced enough lava to form a
planet-wide ocean of molten death
in practice that lava was confined to an
area of 7 million square kilometers in
siberia known as the siberian traps
it's still there today by the way a vast
landscape the size of australia built on
lava fields hundreds of meters deep and
over 250 million years old
but no
it wasn't lavery death that caused the
great dying
it was the resulting chain reaction that
quickly snowballed into a real-life
version of the apocalypse and it all
started the same way your last beans on
toast dinner ended
with some really bad gas
whilst we tend to focus on the more
exciting parts of volcanic eruptions
the lava the pyroclastic flows the
holiday hampering ash clouds
volcanoes also produce an awful lot of
gas that includes water vapor which is
of course harmless but also co2 and
sulfur dioxide
which very much aren't as trillions of
tons of lava oozed up out of the earth
in siberia 250 million years ago vast
quantities of sulfur dioxide dust and
ash billowed up into the atmosphere
blocking out the sun and causing global
temperatures to plummet
the resulting reduction in sunlight
caused massive disruption to
photosynthesis in both the oceans and on
land
since the organisms found at the bottom
of most food chains are
photosynthesizers
like plants and algae this sudden dip in
production caused food chains to
collapse devastating ecosystems across
the globe
what goes up must come down and
eventually all that debris fell back
down to earth
dust and ash blanketed the ground and
choked the air and the sulfur dioxide
which had combined with water vapor to
form acid aerosols was washed out of the
atmosphere in the form of some of the
most severe acid rain ever experienced
on earth this deadly precipitation got
to work murdering whatever plant life
was still left alive
whilst also contributing to a
significant drop in the ph of the oceans
enough to crumble corals and melts the
shells of other sea creatures clean off
their backs
then it was about time that this other
volcanic gas i mentioned carbon dioxide
joined the party
as you've probably noticed co2 is a
potent greenhouse gas
and once the dust clouds had settled and
the acid aerosols had dissipated
all that extra co2 in the atmosphere
began to do its thing leading to an
intense period of global warming
warming that was made even worse by a
monumental stroke of bad luck you see
the siberian traps happen to be located
on top of an extensive coal bed
as rampaging lava ignited these coal
beds on an enormous scale
catastrophic levels of greenhouse gases
including carbon dioxide and methane
were released into the atmosphere
estimates vary wildly but by some
measures it's thought the siberian traps
eruptions contributed to the release of
some 14.5 trillion tons of carbon
about 2.5 times what would be released
if we burnt all the fossil fuels on
earth
at the same time as a result global
atmospheric temperatures shot up by as
much as 8 degrees celsius
scientists today expect some fairly dire
consequences if we allow global
temperatures to increase just two
degrees above pre-industrial levels
eight degrees
is practically unthinkable and it wasn't
just the air that was getting
uncomfortably warm the seas were too
with water temperatures reaching more
than 40 degrees celsius at the equator
that's about the temperature of a hot
tub
which sounds kind of nice but remember
this particular hot tub was full of skin
melting acid and trillions of dead
animals
when you start laying it all out like
this it's kind of surprising that
anything managed to survive the great
dying at all
and i haven't even finished painting
this real-life hellscape yet
with plants and forests utterly
decimated and acid rain pouring from the
skies all over the world
far more bare earth was exposed to the
elements than was normal and so erosion
skyrocketed washing masses of nutrients
into rivers and oceans
that might sound like a good thing
and it was
for a bit the nutrients triggered a
brief but pronounced explosion of life
but when that life inevitably died away
thanks to the increasingly inhospitable
conditions
it sank back into the ocean depths where
the bacteria that fed on it suddenly
found themselves as guest savannah on
the biggest buffet on earth as this
bacteria proliferated it hoovered up
oxygen like a dedicated smoker after a
triathlon
combined with the fact that oxygen is
less soluble in sea water at higher
temperatures
this led to a huge reduction in ocean
oxygen levels all around the world
between this lack of oxygen and rising
acidity from acid rain and elevated co2
levels in the atmosphere earth's oceans
became very nearly uninhabitable
it's estimated that around 96
of all ocean dwelling species died out
nobody knows quite how long it took this
nightmarish process to unfold
early research suggested it might have
been some 15 million years or so but
recent evidence points to a far more
rapid decline perhaps just a few tens of
thousands of years
however long it took everyone agrees
that when it was over
life on earth had been all but
annihilated
it's hard to get your hands on some good
rock samples that span the permian
triassic extinction event
much of it is either long since
weathered away or buried deep beneath
the ground
but the examples we do have
tell a pretty bleak story
with fossil diversity simply
disappearing at the boundary line
even more creepily we also see a huge
spike in fungal fossils around the time
of the extinction presumably because
various fungi were having a great time
chowing down on all the dead plants and
animals lying around everywhere on land
of course not everything succumbs to the
great dane
a few incredibly tenacious species
managed to adapt to the almost
unimaginably hostile conditions
one plucky beasty that made its way
through this storm was lytrosaurus a
proto-mammal that was a bit like a cross
between a lizard and a pig now i know
what you're thinking christ that's ugly
but be careful you're insulting part of
your own family
whilst we humans aren't direct
descendants of these magnificent
creatures they do make up part of our
evolutionary tree
their synapses just like we are and
every other mammal in existence for that
matter
thank god those ugly bastards made it
thanks for watching